innovative and influential women they
are all around us and today we're
taking some time to talk about local
ladies who are doing inspiring work in
their chosen fields and within our
wonderful community
joining us now for a preview of the 2021
women inspiring nevada winners
is vegas inc special publications
manager jennifer inaba
so nice to see you jennifer even if it
is distance
we appreciate your time today we
understand there are 12 honorees that
will be featured in the latest las vegas
weekly issue
all making a huge difference how were
these ladies chosen
sure thanks for having me you know this
all started um with open public
nominations earlier in the year and then
we gathered
the most equipped panel of judges to
review each and every entry
past honorees you know having previously
received the same title they certainly
know how to recognize professional
leadership
and dedication to giving back that makes
the nominee deserving of recognition so
when they're reviewing the submissions
what they're looking for are really
those standouts based on leadership
qualities
accomplishments in their chosen career
or industry um and of course
philanthropic
efforts within our community oh there
are so many of those so true jennifer
well tell us a little bit about the
cover star
yeah you know as are all of the 12 women
aisha mehdi who's on our cover
is amazing she is a local health care
attorney here
with spencer fein an incredibly
important sect of law
obviously especially given this last
year but she also manages to find time
to dedicate
pro bono work to the children's attorney
project with legal aid center of
southern nevada where she's
always out there working for justice for
children in our community
wonderful uh jennifer what else can we
expect to learn in this special edition
issue
sure you know in the issue you'll read
about each of the 12 women their stories
of success and perseverance their
career trajectories and the charities
that they're involved in um this year's
list is
unbelievable you know just to name a few
a little bit there's valerie hicks of
sapphy who advocates for children in the
foster care system and welfare system
kimberly shaw with san martin hospital
who as a trained nurse herself
and she's currently the president and
ceo of the hospital when they hit their
covet surge
she jumped right out there on the front
lines and was helping her staff
and then another one elizabeth blau who
continues to elevate the culinary and
hospitality landscape here in las vegas
that's just a small taste
the the list of women are truly
representative of all the industries all
the work that's being done here and
honestly we're just really thrilled to
continue this publication for the 14th
year um
and we hope especially now as we're
emerging and we're getting excited to
get vegas back
after the pandemic that these stories
sort of inspire everyone for our future
and what's to come for our community oh
they certainly will especially after
this challenging year
all right last but not least when's it
available
tomorrow's the big unveiling um so
you'll get to read all about our 2021
women inspiring nevada honorees it's
featured as part of the cover package
this week as well all right thank you
again for your time jennifer anaba we
greatly appreciate you
don't forget folks pick up your copy of
las vegas weekly when it hit stands as
she said tomorrow thanks jennifer we'll
check in with you
sometime down the line for some more
good news